so Aaron why did you decide this was
gonna be the movie that you directed I
didn't know that it was gonna be the
movie that I directed until after I
wrote it the reason why I wrote it was I
I was sent the book and I was asked if I
would meet with Molly bloom and I read
the book and book is a wild ride it's a
wonderful read that I met with Molly and
she absolutely was not who I expected
her to be I what happened was in a
nutshell
I'll make this story shorter I basically
had the same journey that Charlie has in
the movie
I began by believing I was going to be
meeting someone who was just cashing in
on her brush with celebrity and in that
first meeting which only lasted one hour
I discovered that this was not at all
the one that the tabloids had suggested
or that I thought that and the story
that she had written in the book was the
tip of the iceberg and not really the
real story and the more I talked to her
the more I got comfortable with each
other that that first meeting was the
first of a couple hundred the more I
realized that she was I'm sorry about
the feedback on the mic the more I
realized that she was either a real-life
movie heroine I and an uncommon one
found in an uncommon place you don't
expect that you're gonna find someone
with this kind of integrity with this
kind of character you know in a story
about running underground poker games
and in Hollywood but that is who she is
remarkable and after just that first
meeting I walked away knowing this is
going to be the next thing I write I was
supposed to write something else I put
it aside and I just began chasing this I
had this feeling about it ultimately the
reason why I did decide to direct it was
that I knew
that there was a gravitational pull with
this story that there were other
versions of this story available if you
want them if there's low-hanging fruit
here that you could go after the shiny
objects in the story and say let's just
make it about the decadence and the
glamour and the money and the sex and
the and the Hollywood stars and the
story that I wanted to do was more
emotional other than that it was
different than that it didn't quite stay
in its lane it would move around and
that's why I ended up directing Jessica
you met Molly what kinds of things did
you glean from talking to her that were
helpful to you and in creating your
performance it was wonderful to meet
Molly I actually Erin introduced Molly
and I at the four seasons which I
thought was very appropriate and we had
a coffee with Erin and then she and I I
think went to an art show we started
hanging out and talking and I learned a
lot from Molly I had sadly I'm kind of
embarrassed to say that I really judged
her before I met her I googled images
and saw what the press was kind of
saying I saw an interview that she had
where journalists wasn't very nice to
her and I thought okay I kind of
understand who this girl is
okay I understand this because we all
know the media sometimes doesn't treat
women fairly it may vilify them and and
I think that happened with Molly and the
more I got to know her I was really
blown away by no matter what was
happening she had this sense of hope and
optimism and no matter what you knew she
was going to be okay so I had that
experience of being around her and
talking to her about everything from her
clothes to what she was feeling to her
dad so much about that you know the
patriarchy set up in our house from the
very earliest of Ages and and then I
also had the fortune of meeting the
players that played with Molly and going
I went to a New York game and and
observed people lose a lot of money and
it was a very helpful research process
hey Jess you and Jessica have some great
sort of verbal back and forth can you
talk a little bit about this dialogue
and what it was like for you
particularly since you're having to
change your accent as well as deliver
this kind of rapid-fire Sorkin dialogue
I had had I said it today in the press I
was talking I had a mama I made it
moment when Aaron asked me to do this
film it's a absolute gift for actors to
sort of be invited by Aaron soaking you
know scripts to work on and then of
course the double whammy is to work of
Jessica and of course be directed by
Aaron so I was very very happy when I
got it but of course there's a lot of
words in this film there's a lot of haha
and you know as I've gotten older as an
actor I'm so less confident about
accents it's like to play cockney old
boys now but the truth is is that I was
very fortunate to have the guidance of
Aaron especially with Charlie Jaffe
because of the the nature of the Molly
Jaffe scenes in the film they are a
spine and they're also an indication of
timeline for the audience of the
audience get a chance to check in where
they are with the story with the scenes
as Jessica and Idris were getting to
know each other in these scenes bar
Molly
and Charlie so I basically got this
opportunity to sort of you know you know
understand who charlie is as Charlie was
understanding who he was in the story
and the fortunate thing is that we had
10 days to do all of our scenes because
of the bottleneck of the schedule but it
was fantastic I tell you what I'm not
lying you know we used to show up
Jessica and I would show up and Aaron
wanted us to just show the crew what we
were shooting today which was 10 pages
and so you know Jessica and I did open
theater
everyone sat down with their coffees in
their croissants and no they watched us
futz through these scenes in the morning
which was just an amazing experience for
filmmakers you know we were all sort of
students in a college dorm - sort of
working on words written by the great
Aaron Sorkin but then ultimately we got
this opportunity to start to carve out
the emotional you know journey we knew
the words we had the emails from Aaron
memorize the words we got all that but
the truth is is that Jessica and I got
to you know play about play with the
emotion I got to sort of practice my
accent which meant pretending to be
Aaron and that was it Charlotte how did
you create visuals that would keep up
with these words I mean the the dialogue
moved so rapidly how did you sort of
create the world that we would see
alongside the the sounds were hearing
that was a chance and I have to say
especially for those 10 first days where
we had to cover like 8 pages and create
luckily the the everything in Charlie's
office were dialogue and we didn't need
quite as many shots as we did when we
did the poker games but for the overall
movie it was one of the first things
everyone I met also at four seasons
where I think Aaron has his meetings
when I met Aaron he said the first
things like I can't sleep it you know
with just like how on earth we can't
like it's so many but it was one of the
concerns how do we support the words in
with that rhythm that was in the script
because I think that was one of the big
things about the script is that the
rhythm that sunscreen was in that script
and I felt a huge responsibility to keep
that pace and never slow down and and
Aaron say we just need a lot of shots
but when they actually out there Aaron
was like already you cut it already in
your head and you're like we've got it
we don't need another shots like no
surely like just one more cuz I would
say just in case just in case you want
to do this and I would say I promise you
I've come to that fork in the road and
I've made the decision I want to do this
it is an unnecessary wanted editors were
nodding as charlotta was talking to me
guys tell me about cutting again to this
tempo well first of all there were three
of us
Elia Graham is also one of the shares
credit with us and it bears mentioning
that he came on to work with Aaron
having met him on Steve Jobs and so they
knew each other and had a good
connection and Elia brought Josh on with
him as a co-editor to tackle this big
project and Elliott also at the same
time had to go to London where he is now
within like five weeks of starting in so
he orchestrated a plan to bring me on
and he emailed me and like giedrius said
it was a great thrill to get this
message would you like to come work with
Aaron Sorkin and take my place so I'm
like oh my god yeah so that all happened
and then Josh and I took it from there
but the beginning had been attacked by
Josh and Elliot in terms of figuring out
Aaron's rhythm and that opening sequence
and the percussive editing that his
screenplay and dialogue requires so go
ahead I just say musically he can close
his eyes and tell you if you that did it
wrong because he knows the way that the
words are supposed to be play so it's
that's what's great is that the whole
editing process was about rhythm and
about pacing and about also because
there's so much voiceover in the movie
visualized in the voice-over finding
ways clever ways which allowed us to be
bold I think I and then he could choose
the things where we went too far here's
another idea it was a big experiment but
Darin always encourages us to accelerate
an overlap and keep moving it fast as
interest and Jessica did when they
perform the scenes I kept going further
and further thank you so much for you
very much thank you all very much